first big Republican hearing since
taking control of the house about
Twitter and how they backfired
spectacularly and humiliatingly I won't
refresh that story for you but we then
saw the next hearings the committee
looking into the weaponization the
weaponization of government it's hard to
say it with a straight face this is the
Republican attempt apparently to bring
up Hillary Clinton and Hunter Biden
which seems to be that's their Hammer so
everything looks like a nail this
hearing started yesterday with two of
the most electric speakers you can
imagine Chuck Grassley and Ron Johnson
maybe electric is a bit of an
exaggeration and in this first clip
they're talking about Hillary I mean
it's 2023 and they're talking about
Hillary here is Chuck Grassley oversight
of the FBI very important weaponization
of government
um talking about how Hillary Hillary
colluded with Russia in 2016 apparently
to defeat herself this is so Russia
wanted Trump to win
and Hillary colluded with them I guess
to help defeat herself
we all know now that it was a Democratic
National Committee along with the
Clinton campaign who colluded with the
Russians what they used a former Russian
spy reichen Fusion GPS
and Law Firm to create a fake dossier
this is what happens when you're given
notes you don't understand and ask to
read them it sounds like you don't know
what you're talking about Chuck Grassley
was not the only Republican
senator who brought up Hillary Clinton
here is Ron Johnson just on the Vanguard
of the political criticism space
um also bringing up Hillary Clinton my
first investigation ultimately revealed
the extensive editing of then FBI
director James Comey of his July 5th
2016 statement that exonerated secretary
Clinton regarding her use of a private
email server for officials what's the
deal with saying Clinton I really don't
get that anyway so they Ron Johnson
brings up Hillary as well and then it
really wouldn't be complete unless he
also mentions Hunter Biden which he did
prior to the impeachment proceedings
Hunter Biden's obvious conflicts of
interest in Ukraine became public
and Senator Grafton and I began
investigating yeah the idea by the way
it's beyond power this is sort of like
um
this is like your dog investigating who
knocked over the bin that contains the
treats and ate the entire package of
treats that your dog is not going to be
a great investigator of that uh Chuck
Grassley and Ron Johnson investigating
Hunter and Hillary does not seem like
it's going to get you to the bottom of
anything now speaking more seriously
during her opening statement delegate
Stacy Plaskett a Democrat who is on the
committee because remember even though
this is a republican organized committee
Republicans want this committee they you
have Democrats on these committees she
summed up the committee perfectly
listened to what she had to say I'm
deeply concerned about the use of Select
sub Penny as a place to settle scores
showcase conspiracy theories correct and
advance and extreme agenda yes at risk
undermining Americans faith in our
democracy correct some of today's
Witnesses would have us believe that the
Department of Justice and the Federal
Bureau of Investigation are part of a
deep state cabal right one even wrote a
book describing the FBI itself as a
threat to democracy
the Department of Justice and the FBI do
not always get it right history is full
of examples of these agencies getting it
very very wrong we have colleagues in
this Congress who have been subject to
politically motivated hateful racist
investigations by our government yeah so
she completely sums it up perfectly
which is this is another sham committee
it's not really meant to investigate it
is meant to prop up a narrative that
they have already decided as the truth
and to prop it up based on the
pre-existing conspiracy theories and
wild claims that we've been hearing from
these very same people for two four or
even six years so it is yet another joke
and it doesn't seem like it's going to
get any better anytime soon are you
tired of the same old off-the-shelf
grocery store honey look no further than
manukora our sponsor the honey is made
by bees that pollinate the native Manuka
trees in the remote forests of New
Zealand it gives it a unique dark Rich
delicious flavor that you won't find in
any other honey it is 100 raw if you
look at it side by side with regular
boring honey you can see the difference
I've got my Honeys next to each other on
the counter and it looks very different
manukura is also responsible and
sustainable all manukura honey is
harvested using traditional methods so
you you can enjoy your creamy caramel
honey knowing that the production was
easy on the bees and on the planet it's
a perfect natural sweetener I've been
adding it to my tea and my toast but
because of the amazing complex flavor I
find myself using it in things I didn't
even put honey in before like oatmeal
and yogurt and smoothies I have to admit
my girlfriend once caught me tasting
Manuka Honey right off the spoon because
it's that good it really stands out from
everyday honey so don't settle for the
ordinary honey when you can enjoy the
unique delicious flavor of manukora go
to manukora.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for a free pack of honey sticks
very nostalgic to when I was a kid with
your order a 15 value taste the
difference for yourself the link is down
below